texas republicans seem to have a thing
about volunteering other people to do
things that maybe they don't want to do
remember back in the earlier phases of
the virus
in texas when texas republican
lieutenant governor dan patrick went on
tv and said listen
grandma would sacrifice herself to save
the economy by which
he really met the stock market and then
we said well
grandma isn't dan patrick's to sacrifice
now former texas republican governor and
former trump secretary of energy rick
perry
is saying texans are willing to continue
going without power
so that the federal government doesn't
get involved in their energy market
it's not his role to decide who wants to
go without power
in a blog that was posted on house
minority leader kevin mccarthy's website
rick perry wrote quote
texans would be without electricity for
longer than three days
to keep the federal government out of
their business how does he know that
try not to let whatever the crisis of
the day is take your eye off
of having a resilient grid that keeps
america
safe personally economically and
strategically
personal responsibility right rick perry
can say what he wants
what he's willing to do but who is he to
say
how many days other texans are willing
to go without power
or heat or water for political reasons
what he is saying here is some of you
may die
to keep our power unregulated by the
federal government but that's a
sacrifice
i am volunteering you to make what
for people who maybe aren't up to speed
on this issue understandably
texas has a power power grid that's run
by
uh i believe the the acronym is ercot
e-r-c-o-t
and it's the only power grid in the in
the united states that doesn't cross
state lines
and as a result of that it's not under
the oversight of the federal
energy regulatory commission rick perry
likes that a lot of texas republican
elected officials like that
um and what rick perry is saying here is
because he wants to keep that going it's
the equivalent of saying listen
americans are willing to have an extra
50 000
extra 50 000 people die of covid so that
we don't get controlled by the who
or something like that that's
essentially the equivalent of what rick
perry is saying
now first of all i doubt it from
everybody i'm talking to
in texas nobody even
libertarians and other people nobody
seems okay with what's going on
so that they can maintain their
independence from many other grids and
federal oversight
secondly it's not rick perry's call to
make
if there's a power outage others are
willing to die for rick
perry's separatist views no
that that's that that just can't be and
one other thing on this i've said
despite the hypocrisy of texas
republicans like ted cruz demanding
federal relief money for texas
now but was against federal relief money
when it was needed in new york and new
jersey for hurricane sandy
despite him being a disgusting hypocrite
i don't want texans to go without
federal aid i still want the people of
texas to get the relief money because
they need it i don't want to hold it
back from them because ted cruz is a
hypocrite
but there is a real question here about
if texas refuses to become part of a
bigger broader interstate
resilient power grid should they
continue to be bailed out by the feds
there are options for preventing this by
being part of a multi-state power grid
and they refuse
but then they still want the money when
it fails again i don't want to deny the
people of texas anything but shouldn't
someone make it clear to texas you've
got to join us if you want us to bail
you out you have to join the power grid
because otherwise you're bringing this
problem on yourselves
they had power outages in 2011 for
similar reasons
they got a report telling them how to
prevent this from happening again
they didn't do anything that the report
said and now they immediately and
defiantly
say give us the cash there has to be
some limit at some point
and somebody needs to sit ted cruz down
and talk about it except ted cruz flew
to cancun
in the middle of all of this i want to
talk about that next